guys how is it going so ah bro and I are
going to see Lindsey Stirling tonight
we're going to her show and I came over
and the snapchat spectacles just came
out I think it was today
that is crazy I can't believe you have
some of them look huge thank you to Ryan
on Twitter cuz he said hey I've got some
g1 when I said yes so here we go Disney
official unboxing basically the only way
to get these is through a vending
machine called a snack bot yeah a snap
bot so these are spokes that I really
actually don't know what they're gonna
do so here we are
have you done an unboxing no I don't
even know what to do I feel like I
apologize please forgive me because this
is my first unboxing so I'm probably
doing this all wrong but it's not even a
box we're going to do it off okay oh my
gosh this is my first unboxing here we
go oh
oh can already do they do always be
really exciting also like cousin I like
to smell with the product okay can I
smell a packaging yes don't really smell
name of us okay like something Oh fresh
plastic yep
fresh though lately that was just made
it looks like we've got a little
connector here kind of looks like a
smart connector on the new iPad so I'm
assuming this probably just charges or
something there's also a button here
oh what's that exactly
I hope it's charged because we gotta get
to go ah whoa that was a fancy shape
these are absolutely really cool well I
think you can see Mike Christine hi look
they actually look really good on you
like with your hair everything so it
really fits well like this nug this
feels really good yeah
what what do I do it oh I just hit a
button oh yeah these are your glasses
they should be connected to your phone
they turn on my bluetooth I've got I've
got it on okay install the latest
version of snapchat he's it updated or
in your phone yeah I think so oh my gosh
I haven't updated any of this boomerang
for a girls night I was gonna hang out
and she's gonna teach me about my phone
it'll be a great time there's something
happening on my face right now looking
for me I'll have to keep looking at it
don't move don't move
connecting dude this is wild I just
connected oh my god look back to cools
down it says name your specs this is how
spectacles will appear in bluetooth and
it's got a
of whom how do you continue this might
take a minute okay we've got one minute
because we've got to get to the show I
wouldn't really charge this so press
wants to take a ten second video press
again to extend by ten seconds or press
and hold to stop report I'm gonna take a
screenshot of agamotto forget it
double tap the side o to check your
battery level what does it say nothing
bleats in barrack me no fight maybe
isn't in sight
can you tell isn't it can you see your
batteries I can't see anything
no can't actually see anything it's not
like Google glass no definitely not
different it's definitely definitely
does right okay the specs line up when
they're charging the charging case holds
about four hours did I really did you
bunch of apps from Jesse so I think it
just saves to your memories and then we
can post it oh sure now I'm recording to
the accidently pushing the button funny
this is amazing and I can't wait till
we're 86 years old and we're like
playing with all the new technology that
comes out we're gonna figure it out
we're gonna get great at it we're gonna
be the coolest nanny's ever all right
now we're filming ourselves wait right
now because I want us moving like that
bit see that what does it mean I don't
know if you can see this but you know
when you get this little button yeah it
like
so now looking at this this is the
camera here and this is like the LED so
I'm gonna press it okay so now let's go
recording your video you think the
cameras on this side yes you can yes
okay listen
yep you covered it covered it and then
opened it you know covered it hello this
is cool
goodness gracious well we're gonna take
these specs to the show so stay tuned
holy fun is I don't even know what's
gonna work but we're gonna see what
happens I think it will I like this bin
psych hands-free
you don't even yeah I don't have to open
my app that hold it no it's hands-free
snap just do this cool let's go the show
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's so dark it's not gonna work out
well for the show but I'm gonna push the
button oh my gosh so I can see a light
inside my head
I can see a light inside my head and we
made it to her show just on time guys
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's basically supposed to be a video
about
[Music]
[Music]
you're snapping right now yeah you're a
snapping right now let's see
what this life
[Music]
[Music]
an experienced house Torben was
exhausting but like my favourite tour of
every time there's so much emotion so
much of me in the show and I'm so wet
you guys got to be here with me and guys
there might be a spoiler alert Luna
just one word everything to me that
puppy you guys need to follow her on
Instagram because that's like my
favorite when load opposed I'm sure she
doesn't read I will see you guys over
again in front of me are some new amiibo
a lot of people at this point I don't
think are as into amiibo as they were at
the beginning but those who are into the
amiibo are really into them there's also
the casual amiibo fans so there's tons
of uses for amiibo I guess maybe tons is
sort of a little bit far stretched but
there are as I'm okay I keep saying at
time